please welcome producer extraordinaire
in architect of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige the first thing we're gonna talk
about is something this is again
something Disney Plus is allowing Marvel
Studios to do for the first time our
first animated series called what if now
what if is based on a comic series that
we've loved for years where they take a
storyline you know and change one
element and see how things could get
different so the 23 films of the MCU
that you know we're going to showcase
one little difference in each episode
and see how things change Peggy Carter
herself Hayley Atwell
[Applause]
the Falcon in the Winter Soldier and I
would love you to meet our head rider
mile from Spelman and our director
Carrie Skagen
[Applause]
anthony mackie and so the bass
[Applause]
and I would also love to tell you
exclusively for d23 for the first time
Sharon Carter is returning miss Emily
VanCamp
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and a new character entering the MCU in
this series is a character named John
Walker and he's played by the great
Wyatt Russell
[Applause]
Linds - gentlemen - filmmakers in the
cast of the Falcon the Winter Soldier
coming to Disney Plus thank you very
much thank you thanks guys thank you
very much all right thank you thank you
awesome we're doing another series we've
announced it already it features two of
our most iconic Avengers Wanda Maximoff
and the vision Lizzy Olsen Paul Bettany
are starring in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joining the cast reprising her role as
Darcy Lewis is kat dennings reprising
his role as agent Jimmy Wu from ant-man
the wasp Randall Park
[Applause]
[Music]
the amazing Kathryn Hahn
[Music]
[Applause]
in a cast and the filmmakers of Wanda
vision more to come this being d23 it
seemed like you might want some new
information and you might want to hear
about three new shows we're doing for
Disney pop
so let's reveal the first one miss
Marvel Camilla Kon Muslim Pakistani
teenager from Jersey City is coming to
the MCU it is remarkably exciting for us
you will meet her in her Disney Plus
series and then you will see her in our
films Moon Knight a new action-adventure
series coming to Disney Plus a very
famous Marvel character for many years
marc spector he was a mercenary he was
left for dead in the Egyptian desert and
he now may or may not be infused with
powers from khonshu that moon God or he
might just be crazy it is something very
unique and exciting for us
she-hulk coming to Disney Plus Bruce
Banner is no longer the only Hulk in the
MCU Jennifer Walters is a Hulk she's a
lawyer and she's going to start a show
unlike anything we've done before this
is what Disney Plus is doing for the MCU
it is growing it is expanding it thank
you thank you so much that's what we've
got thank you so much everybody
we're excited it's time for more of us
yeah in the world has come and it's
pleasant I mean it's a first time for
everything
you know I feel like our two characters
have figured out our differences yeah
yeah no we're we're getting you know
we're cruising along better day better
days it's so excited to give people like
pieces it really feels bad to tease out
things with no information and to just
give the information today of Dick Van
Dyke was like oh thank God we can talk
about something now and you could I
think you could feel the audience go oh
wow you know that's it's because it's a
pretty odd
choice would where to take the
characters I mean I I didn't see it
coming and you know and it happens to be
sort of a mash-up between a couple of
our favorite comics that will remain
nameless and and also up but also a
mashup and this is all from Kevin Feige
'he's fevered imagination a mash-up of
sort of American sitcoms throughout
their eras and and it tumbles into a
kind of chaotic messed-up story that
then ends up in more familiar epic
Marvel narrative and that is you know to
have somebody pitch that to you and say
you're gonna have six hours of that to
play around in is very excited to
announce that I'm part of what if which
is a series from Marvel animated series
to kind of play with the idea of a small
detail of the cinematic Marvel Cinematic
Universe had been altered what what the
consequence would be it feels like the
gift that keeps on giving because it's
thanks to the fans that Peggy keeps
coming back so it's you know I live in
the UK and I come here and I sadly go oh
it's this big the scale of it you know
it's it's kind of a limitless expansive
universe and I'm always happy to come
and say hi and be part of it I am a
Marvel newbie so this was the first
thing opened these guys have been in the
Marvel Ward world before so they I've
been in very good hands with with this
very sweet group guiding me through the
madness that is d23 it's very
overwhelming but really was yeah but
it's really fun it's called wanna vision
like what can I say without just all I
feel like something's gonna cut a clause
gonna come from the ceiling it is like I
say the wrong thing
[Laughter]
I said I was told today I heard that I
was playing a nosy neighbor so I was
like okay that's not how I'm gonna
describe myself and then I don't know
how how else to describe it I know it's
Wanda and vision there we're all in it
we're castmates there are sitcoms
involved yes and it should be very fun
and playful and and super-smart and
exciting and action-packed so we're here
today to present Wanda vision we're so
excited we shared a little tonal peace
yeah we don't we haven't started
shooting yet so we wanted to have
something that would give a flavour of
what we're doing so we put together a
piece that intercut the Dick Van Dyke
Show with footage from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe focused on Wanda and
vision and that gives you a little sense
of when we're in movies the movies every
get there's so many characters everybody
kind of gets 15 20 minutes you know and
this is six hours of Wonder and vision
and some fun and a privilege to get to
do it to get to get to lead this cast of
people that are also coming from other
franchises to get Kathryn Hahn involved
in our in our land we're so lucky to
have her I feel like we're gonna have
the time of our lives making this and we
have a great group of people coming
together so I it's just like so much
gratitude to Disney and Marvel with this
character you know especially because he
hasn't had kind of like a moment like
like that it would be interesting for
sure see our pasts and where we come
from I mean I think so there's so many
characters that they're trying to put
into these films that I think it was
really smart on their part to say hey
let's like branch out and give these
characters an opportunity to really grow
within this platform and that's really
fun for us actors because we get you
know a better chance at it you know
because in those movies you're trying to
infuse so much all in these tiny little
moments whereas here get a little bit
more of an extended version at
that so I think it's great I'm really
excited it's nice because we got to dig
you know I'm saying like we being first
up with the serialized story one of the
things that Marvel was really clear on
is we don't want it to be all action all
the time we need to go home with these
characters we need to spend time really
unearthing who they are and since we've
got great actors put them in situations
where they really get to show what they
can do so that was that was a pleasure I
think the most exciting thing about it
is we have six hours now to like really
delve in so like you know low-key and
just take on a completely unexpected
adventure yeah it's exciting it's a
character who people have gotten to know
over the course of several movies but
now with six hours to spend with them we
can do totally new exciting stuff and so
yeah it's gonna be really fun